what are you still learning steve same
stuff
you know same stuff never never stops
and i'm thinking listening to you guys i
mean my experience was not like in
martial arts or something like that it
was more
in in writing day to day of
would i [ __ ] off today you know would i
drop the ball today would i stop you
know or like aubry you're saying you'd
running a little farther on the beach
like what would william wallace do
yeah you know um can i push myself a
little farther
or even beyond the idea of like whipping
yourself or anything like that the idea
of like
um being kind to yourself being gentle
to yourself like if you're
training a thoroughbred racehorse you're
not going to beat the crap out of that
horse you're going to make it fun for
that horse right
right so to do that and like you were
saying joe you
you find a log that's floating you know
this worked today i did this it worked
here it is the end of the day i feel
good so tomorrow
let me try to do that again right and
then you don't you don't quite succeed
you know
but then you find another log and little
by little you put those logs together
and truths start to form in your mind
this works this doesn't work
and then also like you guys say you get
it from other people you get it from
books you get it from conversations you
get it from music
it reinforces itself like this
conversation now is reinforcing it for
me
and i'm sure it's reinforcing it for you
guys too yeah it's like
what's interesting to me is it doesn't
matter what pursuit you're in
the the laws seem to be the same
you know i'm sure that if we had a a a
weaver in here or a potter or somebody
you know that made furniture they would
say the exact same thing you know i get
a piece of wood in
and that piece of wood is telling me it
wants to be a couch
you know um so
it's interesting that there there are
laws
and we're just sort of learning them and
uncovering them as we go and again this
is what musashi spoke of
and this is one of the things that
musashi um
put in his book where he described his
pursuit of calligraphy
his pursuit of poetry right they're all
parallel
[Music]
when you're writing poetry or when
you're drawing something or painting
something
you're still trying to get at that same
source that pure source
whatever it is whether it's a cartoon or
whether it's a stephen pressfield novel
about greek history whatever it is it's
the same thing it's like
it's this weird creating energy that
you're trying to tap into
it's getting rid of that mind boy and
getting into the uh
the higher nobleship what's the
what the [ __ ] is the mind boy there for
though is he doesn't he do something
good
he's good at solving puzzles is what
he's good at he's good at pool is he
is he what makes you play pool he's not
good at pool but he's good he's good
he's good at doing you know doing the
the mechanistic puzzle work
of the human life you know figuring
things out putting on different masks
socially adapting you know modifying
behavior in a certain way
i would call it the ego as opposed to
the self
self with the capital s you know it's
the
it's and maybe we're talking about
tribal ways and
and seeing those mysterious worlds and
all that other thing maybe that's the
self
and somehow when we became civilized we
shrunk it down
to to the ego that knows how to build a
wall or something like that but doesn't
know how to access
and then what what you guys are talking
about what i'm talking about is
breaking through those walls and trying
to get even for just a minute at a time
to that that thing that's got some magic
to it
yeah creating and i feel bad for people
who don't get to create
i really do whether i mean even if it's
creating like at your job
you know whether you're you're a
carpenter or you know someone who puts
things together
like there's something about making
something that wasn't there before and
now it's there
there's something about that whether
it's even just a performance or you know
a song or whatever
there's something about that that's one
of the few magical things in life well
that's
what god does right a legend creates so
we as human beings when we can do that
that's pretty cool
yeah beer also creates nuclear bombs you
know creating also meant what
oppenheimer did
you know it's all creating that's that's
creating as well so it's a very strange
thing that
what you drop out of the enola gay that
kills a half a million people
that's creative too
it's almost there that destructive force
is also
part of you know as part of the creation
you know i was talking to someone who
who i really respect and i was asking
about you know that kind of
um the the demon force you know that
purely destructive force
and it doesn't have to be an actual
angel or demon you know kind of
conceptualized religiously
but whatever that destructive force is
that's tapped in
and and he's basically saying that you
know when that's really high it's just
it's just doing its job you know there
has to be that
that opposing force from which creation
can push forward its strength
you know and so yeah these these nuclear
bombs do it in a
dramatic and terrifying way but that's
one
opposing force by which you know you can
try and flourish life in spite of you
know so
there's some kind of weird harmony in in
all of that that
was created in the soup to begin with
you know everything has to be
find the balance but i do think that we
get way off balance
one way or the other in certain ass and
you see that in people and i think
the key is you know you can really only
there's only one corner of the universe
you can be sure to change and i think
that's a quote from uh
from huxley actually and that's yourself
and that's what you can be sure to
change so bringing yourself back into
balance
everybody does that guess what the
world's back in balance
you know so you can be sure you know
take that step to get yourself
in balance and then slowly all these
other things will start to lay out the
dominoes will
i want to